hello happy Monday we got a little
present from Treyarch and Activision
basically black out beta has been
extended to ours so it was posed to end
at 10:00 a.m. Pacific which was about 40
minutes ago he's gonna go till 12:00 so
we hopped on started earlier than 11:00
who normally we were live at 11:00
obviously but to get extra time into
play we figured why not also they
increase the player cap to a hundred
which is another big deal so we'll see
how that goes
I'm basically gonna try and soloing it
up see how that goes can we play can
play the zombie characters not that you
probably did that the other day and I
didn't even know all right we go what
the f is a couple hour extension hey
still better than nothing
what's up Sameera Smita rather sorry but
thanks everyone for tuning in of course
and I'll be in I'll be monitoring chat
and playing at the same time I do my
best I'll try to win but no promises
we're also going to try to
zoomy zoom a little bit try to get rid
of that empty chair there who is this
dude I'm Eric I'm from GameSpot I work
here how are you doing I'm usually on
our live streams Monday to Thursday and
we're gonna get into Cod's battle royale
black out except this time with 100
players as you can see in the top right
apparently Erin was telling me there was
like a muse on B type 2 and in the game
that's really hard to kill or something
so well let's see if we can find that 2
extended how long matrix cube for 2
hours so not that long do you work from
home for dinner
forget about no I have them actually in
the office in San Francisco right now
Alec two days would be better yeah I
agree
it's a Sharky but you never know they
could always have another beta right
before it actually launches in October
you never know
I just subscribed this part cute thanks
for subscribing appreciate it
extended thank God for how long
unfortunately only 2 hours always you
never know if maybe they extend it again
you know we're going to go
do want to go array I guess arrays all
right I don't know we'll find out
playing a scarlet from these upcoming
zombies what system is this on we're
currently playing on or I'm currently
playing on a ps4
what's up crime how you doing what's up
I'm Skye's two hours no yeah I know
not that long right oh I am NOT phase me
through the wall well I'm so screwed
someone's here really oh I just don't
know I just don't know array I don't
know why I came to array good start
excellent start there's a kill camp now
by the way which is also something they
added that they didn't have but maybe oh
there was actually a lot of people here
oh he was above me okay alright show me
okay
I almost survived it oh the new pope G
update looks scary yeah some people are
joining that comparison that this is
like a more polished version of pub G
and to some degree it kind of is or
resub okay no worries
I missed a beta due to work f my life
says matrix e well you have about a
month and you'll you'll get the game as
well what's up Spencer how you doing
could be someone on the roof he died as
a type yeah it was I heard the footsteps
and I was just trying to grab the armor
and that little Crouch I did it was a me
trying to slide but I didn't get enough
momentum are you on lunch or you just
get to play whenever we stream Monday to
Friday at 11:00 Monday through Friday at
11:00 a.m. Paul and I'm generally here
Monday to Thursday and we're a little
early today obviously but I'm usually
here on stream either helping you know
host and like chat with you guys or yeah
coach Evans been there for a couple days
yeah I know Jordan but from when we last
scream to blackout it wasn't
and yet I don't think but the new thing
is the hundred player cap for sure
what's up Kalani how you doing have you
started using perks save me a few times
on the weekend yeah I mean I've been
trying crime it just depends on if I
pick them up and like which ones I get
we're gonna go into firing range and
probably die a horrible death I gave up
trying to win before the beta ended
actually we got a couple wins
luckily oh shoot I'm jumping out way too
late luckily we want I want my first
match in squads it's probably just a
fluke II win my squad may want it for me
I didn't win a legit one with Rob in
duo's and I won one in squads with Jake
Rob and Ono and Nick margarita all right
we got a pistol better than nothing but
I'm really terrible at the mozu grab dar
when does it end in like an hour and a
half less than an hour and a half uh all
right we gotta stop we gotta stop
dropping they're like in hot spots what
do you think a blackout I like it I like
a quite a bit we did a chat on it I
don't know if it's up yet but we had a
chat about it me Rob and Aaron on the
office you know just to you know talk
about our thoughts on the game like the
good and the bad obviously we had did a
midweek issue last week so I don't think
they added killcam yet they weren't at a
hundred players I think the when we
talked about it they had only gotten to
88 I think dude do you answer questions
at all yeah I tried to trill for real
Windows Veda in 12 o'clock in an hour
and 10 minutes
according to Treyarch you got to
remember there I have some delay so
I'll try to do my best though if true I
made this mode a free-to-play standalone
that would be lit AF I think if I think
people already just want it as a
standalone for not $60 I don't know if
it'll ever be free you have to consider
how much time it probably took to to
make this and I don't know it's just
part of the the cod blobs for package
would be interesting if they ever
decided to sell like zombies as a
separate thing
the Battle Royale is something else but
then you get into that weird kind of
Starcraft air not era but they did that
before where they had instead it's
archived to was three separate games I
think they were each $40 so
Wow just while you're pretty good yeah I
know right you see me get those two hit
markers and then not kill no one I will
try to do better
I've honestly I was playing blackout
with the people in the office but when I
wasn't playing black I was playing a lot
of decimating I'll be honest for those
of you that don't know I play a lot of
doesn't you know what I keep saying I'm
not good over the hot areas but you know
it's got a hope for the best
hi it's a lot like pub G yeah at least
on console I actually it probably is
sort of on PC - I didn't play too much
on PC personally but
let's get a fight I should have kept my
AVR out but whatever
oh hello got legendary we'll take it
sitrep potential collapse detected
relocation indicated safe zone is
advised there's a cluster grenade there
it should take probably I don't use my
equipment enough to be honest
close the door it's kind of weird how
many followers stuff Fuji dang that's
stupid electricity like tripping me the
hell out all right do we make a run for
it in the open ass field with no body
armor high like body armor Oh another
legend mmm-hmm not a huge fan of the
Titan you guys like the Titan trauma kit
I do like it though the only thing I
would say is a little cumbersome on
console Elise is the UI is not as fast
as I'd like it to be just from the
standpoint of like you know what I just
had to do I hit up on the d-pad had to
scroll over you know I can't really run
so I just have to like hide out you know
so I would prefer that I don't know how
you'd do it better on another trauma kit
you're living the dream right now
absolute dream then I'll probably die
with all my good stuff and regret
everything you have like an hour left
yes correct sitrep nice come
yeah I'm not right going that's correct
for some reason I guess people because a
lot of people he's a popular youtuber so
you can see why people I guess will make
that comparison
I don't like I hear a car where the hell
is it it's so loud
where is it better didn't work for you
just got fatal errors that's unfortunate
I have not had any real issues actually
I think maybe I crashed one time like at
most should probably take this buggy
people are still in the rain
like spy like dude there's a guy at all
supply drop incoming okay no idea where
that frag grenade came from but that's
not good I'm being shot at from a place
I don't know where I'm getting shot at
so can you try to try to surf in fine
it's behind me isn't it
stop that jeez
as I go back to peek damn I had to use
my other trauma kit no more body armor
it's all kinds of bad news
where the hell is he shooting me from
I'm moderately confused I think this
body armor is pretty jacked cuz I shot
him in the chest a lot does it gun play
the same as cod stuff yes very much so
I think I saw someone once one person's
complaint that the guns don't feel
different enough which is kind of true
I'm also curious to see what all the
other modes are gonna look like I
thought they had like a CQC one where
they hadn't like know a arse or just
like shotguns handguns and like smg's
they had the fast circle one I could see
them doing like in all legendary guns
mode
that doesn't seem terribly hard to do
why she took the vehicle but I feel like
the vehicle just draws attention
I'd like some new body armor to your
gunshots it's not good like going closer
together oh who do you see what do you
see that your
hey hit that from here be advised
further collapse expected relocating to
safe so
yeah
this is some pub view stuff right now
you know just hiding in the bushes i
dink them once I wasn't sure if that was
actually his arm that's why I didn't
want to shoot I also didn't realize this
head of silence around a pub G smiley
face yeah a lot of fire over here here
the truck again
so much gunfire
let's hear a truck like just like on
this Ridge in a minute five
oh here buggy
jeez
circle collapsed eminent get to safety I
don't get it I don't know where he went
guys a ninja I find a big enough tree to
hide behind your helicopter I gonna go
like to the lighthouse and just like
hang out of hilarious
so it's ending today as of everything we
know yes I mean you might get like an
extra like the extra hour that we have
left but please don't see me
I went down there oh that they're
fighting think
thanks very good
come on you wanna loot that guy
you guys like this a super patient
gameplay oh there's a guy over there mmm
I don't like that you shot at anything
oh I saw you hear footsteps not like
this so what I get for camping sure you
just went in when does the ps4 beta end
it ends in 59 minutes
flute J another hour
we only why only a two-hour extension no
idea Nick maybe they just wanted to try
that hundred or so people I just wanted
to try that hundred player player cab I
couldn't look crime I should have went I
should have went after that one guy so
you played yourself yeah you know the
circle there was still time on the
circle I shoulda knew that but you know
it's about to happen
I can play faster it's just I feel like
my play faster you'll see them if I die
bunch play if you guys rather see like
more immediate combat we could do that I
have no problems doing that
I wanted to say behind you but it would
not been that fun
eliminates all opposition let's try
going asylum see if we can see any news
on
so it's like pop G but in Call of Duty I
guess if you want to make that
comparison be sick if it was two more
days yeah
how he not dying
uh what come on I just need to do good
job oh I'm so dead you got a yellow gun
I'm so dead see you please don't kill me
why so nice killed them no bullets
keyboards please
sitrep potential collapse detected
relocation to indicate it's safe zone is
advised here's the bro go shock them
alive to be honest we're close to a
circle that's good
sorry gonna run this off you so cure
though
your mystery box alone
get a lot of stuff but no armor
so he'll collapse him in and get to
safety
Oh ray gun you got to write even if we
die with it
Jimmy body armor yes only level one but
I'd be okay hope is that person
I wonder he didn't chase me right away
it was a sniper rifle that was the gang
we didn't get the Raygun him I'll hear a
gun somebody though Wow he picked up my
loot really fast Hey feels bad James to
becoming the lone shooter for games like
now there's people doing meetings and it
was like a last minute decision I like
the Raygun - I wish I could have killed
someone for you guys never saw that guy
but again thank you guys all for tuning
in to GameSpot lie really appreciate it
on these like--all last hour or less
than an hour now of blackout beta and
yeah they extended it to 100 people
which is pretty cool it seems like it's
working no problems so far I haven't
seen the supposed new zombie type that
Aaron had mentioned I didn't look that
up though he just told me that there's
like a new zombie that's like really
hard to kill went Asylum didn't see
anything different
zombie why's there
hello
[Music]
you sure you're not rice going yeah
pretty sure I'm not rice go
are you guys in have you guys played
like how how much are you guys liking or
just like in this GATS it's about
another hour
the only extended it two hours total
excuse me
carbonated water
it's a reddish-orange beam of light
blackout
called all the blight father box alright
we'll try to find it you know where is
it just random xxe on traffic is rolling
go go go
I feel like every place is just a death
murder trap see if we can do a little
bit better at array this time
go to the graveyard too late for that
hello random other dude
definitely someone else here somewhere
thank you
potential collapse detected advised
relocation to indicate it's safe zone go
see these zombies
announced myself
hello guys look like you have level 2
armor
chuckle I'm same in and get to safety
I don't know where I was gaining chakra
trying to lose that body booting where
are you there dude
I'll fight you out here in the open
shoot me
sorry stop looking chat good kill Thank
You J Garcia appreciate it
much he's like caught in a battle royale
crap
okay the other thing I don't like is
like in that case and I guess it kind of
makes sense is like if you're full speed
I should have just kept driving actually
if you're like going full speed in a
vehicle and you get off you like take
the damage from the vehicle to so I
probably took like 50 damage from that
vehicle I don't know why I wrote through
that town I should've went around it but
good job on that guy to be on the roof I
guess hanging out what's up high fat
Kosta how you doing yeah and and the
difference here as well is like the
operators each have different equipment
so that equipment is also in the game so
censored art barricades all those perks
are in the game too razor wire trip
mines RC cars helicopters etcetera so
one please mem only sixty dollars
probably can't do that look as a bad
death we had we had some kills to her
name that game at least this is loss
when does this end 45 minutes give or
take unless a decide to extend it again
but as of now we know that it's supposed
to end
all right yeah there are skins J Garcia
you can play as Rezanov Melendez woods
I'm playing us some of the zombie people
right now
you lost cousin Satan in six six six six
people in chat GG oh yeah
infiltrate engage and destroy
this is better than acting multiplayer
properly
I don't like fracking rather go to River
town and die there
did they extend it for all systems I
believe so Kyle splinter
you basically need to use half a clip to
even think about damaging someone
it's so stupid gravy talk that's not
true if you get head shots that
obviously helps of course um and then it
also depends on how much body armor they
have they can still tweak how much
damage body armor can absorb well I
don't think it's that bad
but it does feel tough when your
opponent has body armor and you don't
though for sure but like I said if you
go for head shots you'll definitely be
okay I think sitrep
potential collapse detected relocation
safe zone is advised why are you closed
doors I guess
heard she'd not have joined that fire
should not have joined that fireplace I
mean there's two other guys enjoying
this as Fuji seven yeah it's a fight
it's pretty fun I'm enjoying it damn I
was good little start though you only
really I think I only really notice
people with body aren't like it's
because if you're hitting someone that
has body armor in the chest obviously
he's gonna take longer so like body
armor I leveled like two and three feels
three is actually really scary they take
a lot of damage other than that I think
one and two are fine but as mentioned it
does feel bad when you don't have body
armor and they do because if you're not
hitting them in the head you're probably
gonna die cool game work a 40 minutes
until the street art nice dream but full
stream and the beta yn according to what
they have tweeted Treyarch added two
additional hours to the beta as well as
increasing the player cap to a 100 so 10
a.m. was when it was supposed to end but
now it's going till 12 so that's why
we're playing wanted to get in one last
session with y'all before the you know
either
last beta or you know until release or
maybe they'll have one more
okay skin seemed to use a remind me Ryan
Daniel and I think maybe J Garcia to
check it after this game for you guys
and I'll show you some of the skins that
they have so far in the beta it might
not be all of them do you think EA will
come out with the similar game I don't
think so I mean if they're gonna try
that then AAB they'll do it in
battlefield ahead you try converse I I'm
just worried about getting hit markers I
panic enough as it is when I'm fighting
people I would try to aim for the head
but at least for me I feel like when I
try to aim for the head it tends to not
be the head I know but yes it is good
advice though for sure I'll do my best
oh there's a lot of folks in the firing
range as to be expected
well I'm screwed
please can I get body armor thank you at
least you won't get body election
suspended
and all right let me I just wanted to
show you guys the skins just want to
show you guys what it was all right so
here are all your zombie characters that
you can play as Bruno Dempsey Diego
Nicolai whoa what happened to Nikolai
alright he's okay now alright just can't
go over them too quickly what in the
hell is going on are they okay now okay
they're all okay now right
that was like potato mode anyways and
then you have all your operators from
blackout for black ops for jesus black I
was such a good name he plays them and
then also as mentioned there's woods
Maison Menendez res knob here we'll play
as Menendez and you can kind of make
your own character but the tools for
those aren't that extensive an extra 40
minutes Kansas cowboy jr.
well I see more zombie mascara
throughout the masters J Garcia maybe
maybe a killstreak mode working in a
c-130 no no about that they should
remove Armour only have the one armor
it's an interesting proposition Rascoe I
think that it's nice to have tiers of
armor but if the time to kill is too
long they could just technically lower
the scaling of each piece of armor so
that it doesn't feel as crazy as it is
but it's nice to find level through your
armor though because it's not like that
easy to get and usually like they're in
boxes or you have to fill zombies or
maybe they make level three armor even
more sparse and then you can really only
find like two and one like relatively
easily
you know either like a Supply Drop for
level three or you know go to a zombie
spot to get a level three and maybe
that'll get like more people to go there
because they know that there's level
three armor there when is a free beta
that I don't know I'd rather play
multiplayer says that the actually if my
one friend assuming you mean called
multiplayer just traditional he is a big
Call of Duty fan and he played a few
matches a bad or a blackout and he just
wasn't into it he's like I rather just
play a traditional Call of Duty I'm sure
there's gonna be some of those folks as
well that you know this doesn't
necessarily resonate with that place
when does it come out for Xbox video for
blackout blackout for it should have
been out this weekend oh we're gonna
drop a new count and die a horrible
death let's do it maybe we can get
downstairs into the the secret bunker
and then hopefully nobody's shows up
there right away well chances are
everyone else is not everyone but
there's probably gonna be a good amount
of people here that are gonna try the
same thing as I'm doing if they even
land ahead of me you like that oh we're
screwed
all right kill that other guy that's in
front of you
there's a guy right there just want a
gun there's a dead Menendez well good
news
I can flashbang someone and used my
scope to scare them off okay
equipment RGB for a R&D brief he
literally just potato
that was good I was real good all right
should I get
this will be the longest three weeks of
my life says William Watson you'll be
fine
have you seen land mines or anything
like that it's mesh mines mesh mines are
probably the closest thing to land mines
so yes they are in the game though
hooray another battle royal FPS this
will finally out-out me to sleep well
manual it's that's just how it goes if
you if you're a gamer and you understand
like gaming trends things are gonna
happen like that like mobile is were
thing for a while you have hero shooters
for a while you have collectible card
games like our stone and now shutter out
when will that trend stop who knows I
think that battlefield and Cod will be
the last two big ones to try it I wanna
say reception has been pretty good for
good morning mr. Tay what's up JB how
you doing
heard you had to fend off some people
Ronnie go go go
drop the dying asylum it's white hot red
dead redemption to cowboy beat Battle
Royale
I don't I honestly don't know if
Rockstar is going to do that Oh Lord
there's so many people dropping out
can't wait a diet Asylum
very good
hello hi I like that 9 bang got nobody
sick things are slightly feeling better
now though potential collapse detected
advise relocation indicated safe so
[Music]
there was that better for you okay we
whipped like crazy I so need to grab
that first aid
yeah I left Moody
Supply Drop inbound a curious where that
other guy went
when you went downstairs
oh my god he's I'll ah
Raksha to me GG bad feels bad well
played well played sir I actually
thought I killed them I was wrong
oh yeah des trauma kid alright
my ps4 took a dump right before the
second week brah oh that sucks
glad they did Champlain says William
Watson yeah I'm curious like how many
people like what the percentage of Cod
players actually played the single
player yeah I'm guessing it's not as
because people make it out the same that
they would sacrifice well we shouldn't
say that they just made a decision and
some people will say that the sacrifice
did for a better al but do you think
this will be better than the battlefield
5 better oh I have no idea it's hard to
say don't even know what the battlefield
5 battle rail looks like how long is the
battle a blackout extended for like 30
more minutes it was extended for two
hours on top of when it was supposed to
go down that probably nobody is going to
venmo you if you keep asking them
appreciate it if you didn't keep asking
yeah just where I would find a Spitfire
in the bathroom I missed him a shot
first thing is this - agency I like it
but I enjoy cod so having a different
style of multiplayer is pretty cool
especially since I think 600 much all
will start but don't finish the campaign
agency says I think singleplayer was
bigger back then but now it's like 50/50
IMO problem
I will keep it real ain't nobody
donating yeah I know for sure and that's
funny coming from a person whose name is
free meals not that like means anything
necessarily just what are the odds tanks
are in battlefield 5 royale could affect
balance yeah but maybe that's the style
they want to go right maybe they want to
try doing the a vehicle style
that's my shadow styled about our alpha
maybe nobody's you know really like yep
I have that bad habit I like picking up
stuff that you don't need to you should
like pretty much pick up a gun right
away and then grab everything else after
all so I don't know how I feel about it
like auto-switching do whatever gun you
pick up potential collapse detected we
know the primary location safe so
looking for some firefights
making noise
here's a the mesh mind or the person
asking about minds earlier don't know if
I'll get to use it I don't think
anyone's gonna come here though wow you
get three shots of this thing it seems
kind of - Wow
okay you get two that's really good
actually
and the game proper you scream like only
gets two like I shouldn't have wasted
that to be honest you only get to use
that once or like you know it's like a
skill you only get to use that um shoot
the - so you got double the quantity
there yes you can still play it yeah for
another 25 okay I'm gonna get to safety
unless they decide to extend it even
more but that's what they had mentioned
okay there's a person at the red house
we could swim to them
extended beta troll no I kill - oh I
coast one with the mines lol who would
have thought I didn't think anyone would
still be there tbh can I not jump up
this hello much life do you have I can't
tell how much life he has cool oh yeah a
trauma kit though but place all the
traps don't leave the house yeah the
circle is moving in crime
sweet mind kill I know right alright and
mines it's like it's like running what
you call it all over again oh my gosh my
end of to noob tubing and like you would
run that one class where just drop
double mines and like new tube it was
your weak legs yeah clearly I have no
jumping ability apparently never skip
leg day this is this is true advice this
is a hundred percent your advice
thanks Bryce appreciate it
I hope they'll extend it more yeah who
knows stay tuned to Trey arcs
Twitter because that's where they
announced that they were accepting it
[Music]
web platform ps4 servers must be glitchy
now I'm obviously
do you think Vin Diesel play blackout
maybe there's a ps4 beta still going on
yes /
heyö is hi LC is a free-fire zone good
walk there got to go later legit style
appreciate you stopped client oh we gone
in Newtown
you notice any difference in playing
styles between you can us players not
really poco but I mean like I don't know
how I'd really be able to tell I don't
know which region they're playing from
you know oh I just ran into someone come
into my house okay cover all our bases
not really I didn't cover this window
whatever we get the random kill we get
the random kill potential collapse
detected at 5 3 location to indicate it
safe so big plays
big deaths coming in what kind of far
huh
suppose we should go sick flash flash
squad destroyed by hostile action empty
sea suspended plane well no this is sad
maybe they'll extend anymore who knows
all right I gotta I gotta step my game
up you know what I blame it on Menendez
some work of noble notes may yet to be
done I feel like that is that really
what Mason would say there you ready to
make history that's that's more like it
yeah they just started 100 today right
yes yes I'm struggling right now I
appreciate you guys all hanging out
regardless of the struggles 9 bang is
really strong that scared me
yeah 9 bangs really strong especially if
you cook it all the way Jr I shall get
free kill even to multi-player rip
fortnight I don't know about that you
got to remember for tonight's free
rashad long is not a fan of war night
will just always fair needs to be
extended to lunch that would be kind of
insane but maybe I doubt it though it's
always a comic hit on that specific spot
maybe that's why people from the firing
line they sent him for 17 more minutes
it was a few hours on top of the
original mission clock is running
now we're gonna go to this random spot
on the map it has no like name
Convention to it and hope no one goes
there except it looks like everyone's
gonna go there whatever feeling good
about this one
I'm kind of curious if if like this will
actually shut off right as well or like
if you're in a game if it'll let you
finish
oh no other people have the same idea as
me alright at least we have a combat axe
there's definitely a guy in the like
other house that's where I expect the
first aid in the bathroom I would expect
water armor in the in your walk-in
closet well there's barricades as well
in this game you guys in there
alright so huge rental potential
collapse detected location indicate a
safe zone is advised no don't try again
here we go
Munim hope for the best
no idea what he was doing but we'll take
it we're in the circle net call supply
drop incoming
hmm
give me all these other
that's a hard fail all assets lost
circle collapsed eminent get to safety
did he just stay in that house the whole
time
oh he knew he was just waiting he's just
waiting you what a flashbang see what oh
he had no HP door Noah medkit stuff yeah
that was good corner cornering on his
part
even while hiding else think everything
should be free like I know I don't mind
microtransactions in the game if they're
just skins cuz it's like cosmetic and
you know if you choose to buy them cool
if you don't whatever I'm sure you'll be
able to earn points still to get them
it'll just take you longer right if
they're just cosmetic who cares is how I
look at it I know it's not necessarily
the best thought process but I just
don't like it when you get an advantage
of the game if you don't get an
advantage whatever look like whatever
you want to for all I care I'm not gonna
buy any skins unless like I just happen
to earn like enough silver or coins or
points or whatever you have in the game
but we're winding down here we got 13
minutes left in these supposed of
extended beta here so we'll try our best
to do some work here even though I think
the best I've known is three kills and
having a bad top ten how could you not
see him oh I saw I just didn't see that
guy up
he was the one waiting for me because he
could hear my footsteps so he was just
hangin out so this war bit ends today
right well according to what Treyarch
tweeted yes Delta swag
mission areas hot weapons free
let's try to get a Raygun again
there was three more people around you
yeah I figured that there's a lot of
people around me here where is he gonna
go through
I'll gun out late and out of luck
potential collapse detected advise
relocation trying to hunt that one guy
uh it's a good day I should probably
just wait yours or squad Caesar get
kills
five around you yeah there's a bunch
around me she wanted a ray gun just want
a little ray gun you know you still
haven't went to the graveyard
all right Austin I'll go to the
graveyard the graveyard I'm assuming is
in the in the in this island
where is it because the graveyard
isn't it like next to asylum or is it
farther down I can't remember where is
exactly where is the gate guard
feel like there's anything like in this
area
Soho starfrit try hards wife yourself
this that's cuz I bought myself it's
fine
you're not wrong in that though that
they're poison try oh I should have
looked to see if there's another mode to
be honest below Asylum next to Asylum
where the road makes a loop so like here
or here there you hear here where you
see the trees on them there's a lot of
trees on the map man sit here or there's
a loop here so I'm guessing it's here
pointing over it this one hope it's that
one
doesn't make beta in like 10 minutes yes
I was gonna try to make it over there
yes everyone says yes yes yes all right
we're going there and it's pretty far
from everyone else so I think we should
be good Aaron you got eight minutes
supposedly I haven't checked the tweets
in a while because they extended it
today obviously but I don't know if they
extended it longer anything ten minutes
well basically a place I would get
kicked out but I'm trying to go to the
graveyard because that's what the chat
wants see
that's on the assumption that we get
Auto kicked at 12 like if they just shut
down the servers at all
that really the graveyard or is it above
the circle oh there it is oh I am so far
from like anything whatever alright
there's there is a sec graveyard get
this last dub I don't know about that
I'll be happy to get a couple kills we
got a buggy just good I can't jump over
that okay
make sensors there's spikes there's
spikes we wouldn't want to someone
crying crazy for that potential collapse
detected advisory location to indicate
it's safe zone alright what is what is
why did we come here
that's weird that the body room is still
there even though I picked it up why do
I hear people oh it's grave-robbing I
mean technically is funky no I'm not Sam
we're just kripp keeping right now you
know
zombie noise and red box lights
so baht now we've just been around for a
long time
904 breezy make sure stopping by
appreciate that little - where's the red
box light supply drop inbound sitrep
circle collapse imminent get to safety
did we do everything we wanted to there
I don't see the red light box
does it appear then get it to appear all
zombies
one more minutes I hear not crazy right
oh it's just here a car though
that is the asylum I know well we get
kicked
that's the question or will we get to
finish our match where am i die before
that happens for all I know
now like this at least have someone kill
me or let me kill someone one or the
other
here a car
why are you let us fight three more
minutes
I know trying to find somebody it's 36
left for me just running around in a
circle because I can't find anyone
what up smart gaming yeah we got two
minutes oh there's somebody in that car
but he's easily vain' oh he just flipped
his truck bomb wash up there's totally a
dude there we're following that guy
fight him with this LMG up close because
I'm not a smart player but we had shot
him because I was told I should headshot
more alright at least we got a kill
before the stream ended so my monkey
friend
and here the buggy where are you
all right well we'll get to keep playing
one minute
be advised further collapse expected
relocate the safe zone go to the train
station probably gonna get kicked before
that are you really looting I mean yeah
why not
we're gonna go for a swim assuming the
game will let us go for a swim
oh no okay it's 12:00 I'm still in the
game
my guess is maybe we get to finish this
game you got like the best gun in the
game I don't know about that I'm not a
huge tighten up and whatever we'll see
if I can we'll see how we do
okay now put that on this no idea medic
does anything lentils fam all this stuff
so we might not get to use it I hear
gunfire
sit Rep circle collapse I'm gonna get to
safety people are still playing on
Twitch any other game SWAT teams fans of
fighting X later ask Dave Atkins yeah
Peter was having some fun with it I
think Ben jankle is having fun with it
just cool that DDR skullomania back last
game I don't know I mean who knows it's
really good for tap fire ok just tap
fire I will try
are they still playing new games though
or is it just like the remnants of like
a game they're in like I am
Supply Drop inbound
you know that feeling when you don't
know what half the stuff goes but you're
just like whatever it's all good
this map is extremely similar to oh is
that a shadow
please tell me someone else likes all
that shadow and I'm not the only one
CDN starting a new game oh wow okay
thanks for the heads up Cruz well I mean
if it's still active we can play till
like 12:30 I suppose
we'll see where the next circle is
before we start moving well there'd be
any difference on beta in actual game um
you know they're all there might be some
adjustments like fine-tuning maybe
armors not as strong damage 100 players
now she you crazy
yeah Yolo I didn't even know that was
what oh my god
exit get us out of there
sitrep circle collapse I'm gonna get to
safety
no one gets to use that yeah I'll be
hilarious if I need to use that finally
helicopter action damn never seen a
Hellion action yeah I almost flew myself
to death I would have been not so good
I'll never know that I'm in this window
this bathroom I really have to use the
bathroom actually all right so that guy
totally landed over there and is in that
building I probably shouldn't even be
peeking over there because he's probably
just like gonna snipe me or something
your sniper okay there's a buggy down
there Supply Drop inbound that's a
pretty nice house you got this
yeah that is a big difference as virtual
gamers up there's a guy over there I
mentioned that
for nine players by like the third
person so they can see like you know if
someone's like rolling up on them or
that's how they get their shot gunshots
oh there's a person right there I'm not
even gonna bother shooting I don't think
at one I can land a shot too
I'm gonna expose myself do you like
playing Cod series I do yes we're
chilling I don't want to engage and
someone just killed someone with a Titan
oh it's getting hot now the squabbles
are real I don't yeah I don't know
better maybe I was too high up in the
air I'm not really sure to be honest why
I was almost like gonna be pulled out of
the zone or whatever
be advised in the safe so we are very
much in the circle can we camp this out
a one kill a to kill win maybe well
someone just died
technically alpha wolf it should've been
over but some people are saying that
they're still playing so I don't know
we're in a top-ten situation with one
kill
so not really to fan up there's a guy
down there can you play of two team of
two after I mean I can do oh is but I'm
not gonna deal with anyone the stream if
that's what you're asking me all right
eight people left the circle has been
fortuitous until I have to you seem to
have improved your gameplay you mean I
slowed down and I stopped having to
fight people I guess if you count that
Alright top six by sleeping here yeah I
know it's boring Ivan but that's what
you do that's what you gotta do when you
want to win man if you played any battle
royale game also because I said this was
like following my last game so don't
mess up says crime yeah I'll probably
mess it up I'll probably find a big way
to mess it up some guys are just gonna
jump through that door and shock of me
CD and just started another game stop
camping it's work yeah well do you want
me to win or do you want me not to camp
cuz I'm not about to okay fine here I'll
stop
there now we have exposed ourselves and
we are more likely to lose now
there there's you're not camping okay
there's a guy over on that ridge line
it's definitely a guy in this building
what to see what the circle does here
car
that you hurt himself with the car
somehow oh he's up there now close the
door
Nicole supply drop incoming
oh is that in my house
I sure can glass break
the old sit on the bathtub
camp it out you got it back because I
can't shoot through that and someone
died in my house yeah he's in my house
he must have heard me messing with this
I wanted to mesh mine so badly so dumb
and then the the razor wire was exposed
dad there's two people in this house you
see all that noise I'm making because of
the razor wire that was so dumb how does
he even know I'm there
cuz of the door that was so dumb
y'all see this is what happens
here I just want to see if yeah so much
camp for this yeah you messed it up yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah thank God
here we'll see if the game still up I
think the game is still up yeah I need
to turn down the loud noise of the plane
yeah I couldn't hear death of a classic
definitely camper dude if I was smart I
would a trip mind the house beforehand
and then really stayed in that house but
I didn't think the circle would be that
fortuitous oh now I can't find a match
I think servers might be down now
yeah the sounds that I made with the
with the the frickin razor wire
brilliant yeah it looks like it's GG's
guys oh yeah says thank you to everyone
that joins us with the blackout beta
your feedback was tremendously helpful
and we can't wait to jump back online
with you on October 12th what was your
favorite blackout moment from the beta
my favorite blackout moment of this beta
so far is when I tried to mesh mine at
or and then had that mesh mind blow up
somehow miraculously because he should
have not had an angle at that and at
that um mesh mine but that's my favorite
moment so far what are your favorite
moments anyways thank you guys for
tuning in to our you know final two
hours there give or take of blackout
beta increase cap of 100 never did get
to see that zombie unfortunately but if
you want to see more plays like the
plays I just made at the end there with
that mesh mind you should stay tuned a
GameSpot live Monday to Friday
technically wanted Thursday because
Friday's community Fridays but 11 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time subscribe for more
terrible self kills like that and you
won't be let down I promise you until
tomorrow I hope you guys have a good
rest of your Monday I hope you enjoyed
blackout if you got to play I hope you
got to hang out and have fun I
appreciate everyone being here my name
is Eric see you later bye bye
you